[Music]  every big decision that happens in terms  of the monarchy william and his father  are involved so i think having that  proximity being able to see the queen  much more easily more frequently you  know a few times a week rather than once  a week is going to be great for both of  them  [Music]  [Music]  i think it's great that they're coming  back to windsor where it feels like they  belong to me so yeah it's lovely news  [Music]  prince george is going to be king one  day that's an enormous thing for anyone  his his childhood years they want you  know to give him the best possible  chance of having a normal life before he  starts to contemplate that